-Welcome back, John!
-Yeah, it´s great to be back.
-So happy to see you.
Since you were last here,
you had a wonderful portrayal
of Winston Churchill
in "The Crown."
-Yes.
-Deservedly won an Emmy for it.
-Yes, I did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That...
Obviously, you´re
approaching a character
so many actors have played.
And you are an American so you
have to do the British accent.
I heard you had
a way of approaching
your Winston Churchill voice
that is just very unique.
-Well, he was a unique man
in every way,
including the way he talked.
I sort of --
I knew I had to
develop exactly
the right Winston Churchill.
He had a very jowly face.
-Yes.
-And I remembered Marlon Brando
in "The Godfather,"
and I thought, "Well, I´ll
stick something into my jowls."
I practiced this at home before
I went to England to join them.
With a melon baller,
I created these
little apple balls
and stuck them in --
[ Laughter ]
And I just stared at the mirror.
"I have nothing to offer."
I thought, "I´ve got it!"
-Wow!
-I actually took a melon baller
with me to England.
-Wow.
-And arrived --
-And you got
right through customs.
They had no issue with it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
I was not stopped.
And took an apple to rehearsal
one day, and I said,
"I just want
to experiment with this."
And I dug out two apple balls
and put them in my jowls...
-Sure.
-...and spoke a scene with it.
About 40 seconds in, my mouth --
It sounded great.
It sounded very Churchillian,
but my mouth
was full of apple juice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Turns out
that was Churchillian, too.
-Yeah, exactly.
Winston Churchill famously
spit out apple juice
every 40 seconds.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s what I said.
Nickname.
-So you´re playing
Will Ferrell´s father.
Perfect casting.
-Yes, it was so great.
-And you are,
of the two fathers in this film,
you are
the more emotional father.
-That´s right.
-Yeah.
-Mel Gibson
plays Mark Wahlberg´s dad.
-Yeah, less emotional.
-Yes.
He´s the sort of tough-love
kind of severe,
hard-ass partner,
and I´m just sloppy sentimental,
bursting with emotion.
And Will and I,
as father and son,
we completely adore each other!
[ Laughter ]
-That´s fantastic.
I know you shot in Boston.
You actually got to spend a week
together as a cast at a resort.
Is that nice?
-Oh, yeah.
-Because I know often
you actually do movies
and you don´t get to spend
that much time together.
-Yeah, and it was good,
because we were all nervous.
I mean, we had --
We knew we had to turn into a
four-person ensemble very quick.
It was wonderful.
We were in the Berkshires
for a week.
We had to get as much snow as we
could before the Spring came.
And it was just
a great bonding week.
-You had a great bonding,
it sounds like,
the entire time on the set when
you did the film "Footloose."
You actually
all hung out together.
And that seems like a place --
You filmed that in Utah?
-We filmed it in Provo, Utah.
-Mm-hmm.
-A very conservative
little community.
-Very "Footloose"-ian.
-Very "Footloose" --
Footlusion, I think.
-Yeah, Footlusion, you´re right.
I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
-And Dianne Wiest and I,
were the oldsters.
We were about 25 years younger
than we are now,
but we were the old --
the old folks.
And all these fabulous
young kids -- Kevin Bacon
and Lori Singer
and Sarah Jessica Parker.
Somehow or other, we, as a
sort of compensation for that,
we became the wild ones.
-Oh, you and Dianne...
-Yes.
-...had to be cool
to show to the young people.
-Yeah, yeah.
We all stayed in a motor court.
And I was sort of
the venerable older star,
so I was given two rooms
with an adjoining door.
-Oh! Wow.
-So I threw the parties.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-We had, like, "Soul Train" --
You know, it was just crazy.
And these young kids
thought we were nuts.
-Yeah.
But you had a good time.
Did you ever get in trouble
with the Provo authorities?
-Yes!
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah, we flung off our clothes
and leaped into
the swimming pool one night.
-Oh, that´s not --
I don´t think that´s
supposed to happen
at the Provo motor court.
-And we got
a very stern dressing down
from our producer
the next morning.
Dan Melnick, so...
But that happens.
-Hopefully, you learned
your lesson, John.
-But it was odd,
´cause in "Footloose,"
I was the guy who wouldn´t
let anybody dance.
-Yeah, but turns out that
you´re too busy
doing other stuff,
skinny-dipping, to dance, yeah.